- You ready to talk about your emotions?
- Not really. (laughs)
- Every guy, no guy's been excited
to talk to me about their feelings.
(mid tempo music)
As a man, do you feel comfortable
expressing yourself emotionally?
- Not at all.
- No, but sometimes, yeah.
- I feel comfortable
expressing myself when I'm mad,
but not like, emotionally,
like, oh, I feel feelings, no.
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
- I do, yeah, I totally feel comfortable.
- Uh, yes.
Sometimes it depends on the emotion.
- Tristan's a Cancer, he told me this.
- Yeah.
- So it makes a lot of sense.
- Because of the man I am,
a man of trans experience,
I actually oddly feel more
comfortable expressing myself
as a man than I did before I transitioned.
I felt like I had nothing to prove
and I could be as emotional
as I wanted to be.
- I think it's a fear of
like, being vulnerable.
- So you would say like crying,
you don't feel comfortable--
- I don't cry in front of people.
- When was the last time you cried?
- Probably like a year ago.
- Yeah, I don't remember
the last time I cried.
- Have you cried this year at all?
Do you think you've cried this year?
- I don't know, I don't think so.
- Intense shit, I won't cry,
I'm stoic as fuck, I don't care.
It's like I intellectualize everything.
- When I cry I don't just
like, medium cry, I ugly cry.
- But that's okay, 'cause you're getting
them feelings out, though!
- No, no!
- I didn't want, I just want that like...
I want that one tear.
- That one tear?
I just want the one tear.
- That thug tear.
Jared wants a thug tear.
- Yeah, I want a thug tear.
- I cried when I went to
Hong Kong for six months.
That was 2010.
(laughs)
- It's not, it's like not
okay to feel vulnerable,
so I'm already conditioned
since I was a kid
that men do not cry, so.
And the problem with that
is now I have a problem
being vulnerable in front of people.
(jazz music)
- Professor Ad Vingerhoets
of Tilburg University
studies crying and has
found that women cry
on average 30 to 64 times a year,
compared to men who cry A,
three to four times a year,
B, six to 17 times a year,
C, eight to 10 times a year,
or D, five to eight times a year.
- Me knowing me, probably three to four.
- If we're going based
off of like, what men say,
I'm gonna say five to eight times a year.
- Probably eight to ten.
- Final answer?
- Yes.
(buzzer sound)
- It is six to 17 times a year.
- What's wrong with me?
- Yeah, I believe that.
- I think it's more than that.
- Guess they probably cry
more but don't cop to it,
or they like, black it out,
or they don't think of it as like, crying.
- Last year was the last
time you cried. (laughs)
- That's what I'm gonna tell you.
(laughs)
- True or false.
This 1999 study of 81 participants
from Harvard Medical School
and Boston Children's Hospital
found that six-month-old boys
were more emotive than girls.
- I say true.
- I would say true.
- I'm gonna say true.
- You is right, Jared!
- (whooping) I knew that, knew it.
- Yay!
- I have a three year old
boy who lives under me
and that guy is like, so emotional.
- A 2011 study from the
University of Missouri
found that boys do not
discuss feelings because
A, they are afraid to
talk about their feelings,
B, they think it will make them look weak,
C, they are biologically
wired to not feel the need
to express emotions,
or D, they don't think it's useful?
- I would say B.
- Definitely B.
- They don't think it's useful.
- Well, you should have went with your gut
'cause it's actually D.
- Yeah, Rocco, yeah Rocco!
- Yeah!
(laughs)
That's how I feel,
I'm like, who cares.
- The writeup on the study was that men
are more likely to think
talking about problems
will make the problems feel
bigger than what they are,
so instead of talking
about them, they'll engage
in activities to take
their mind off of them.
- That's definitely not me.
For me, it's just like,
I don't wanna look weak.
- The same study also said
that women have a habit
of over-talking their feelings
that can produce more
anxiety and stress, so.
- I know what you're talkin' about.
(laughs)
- Oh, really now, Jared!
- Emotions are a burden,
I don't got time for that.
- I feel like we need to
learn how to cultivate a world
in which it's not
necessarily being a burden,
but it's like, you know, I care about you
I wanna make sure you're doin' the best.
- Yeah!
And I just want us both
to be able to equally
communicate that to each other, you know?
How do you think that we can move towards
that kind of world,
like especially for men?
- We gotta promote self care more.
- I think it's important for men,
and for anyone who's
struggling with emoting,
to know that it's not a sign of weakness.
- I think we gotta
continue raising our kids
and telling them, hey,
listen, it's okay to cry.
It takes courage.
- I love a good cry.
Like a nice, like, solid...
'Cause then you just get it all out.
All that pent up
energy and emotion, yeah.
- Get it all the way out.
- Yeah, drink it up sometimes.
(laughs)
- Drink it up!